well here we are with the secret word of
world of oil your your new book on the
seamy underside of the oil business and
so I'm gonna ask you the first question
that every author has asked you must be
sick of answering why why did you decide
to read this book well I have worked
about the I've written about the the oil
industry for a long time for over a
decade and I've written about the
corruption of the international oil
industry and the way the United States
maintains close relationships with
various pretty unattractive regimes and
the basis of the relationship is oil so
for example when I was at the Los
Angeles Times back in 2002 I think guys
I think that's when I first started
writing about the topic and I wrote
about the Obiang family of Equatorial
Guinea which you know small West African
country half a million people nobody
knew about it or cared about it it was a
pariah state you know terrible
dictatorship and dirt poor and then in
the mid 1990s Exxon found a lot of oil
off the coast of Equatorial Guinea and
other American companies poured in and
suddenly the relationship changed
suddenly it was no longer a pariah and
there was this close still not a
friendly relationship because it's a
little too embarrassing but there was a
reappropriation confirm time to time and
I that it was purely really a
coincidence I was looking at another
story entirely I was interviewing a
former general whose firm had gotten a
private contract to help Equatorial
Guinea develop a Coast Guard and he
started telling me about the place and I
thought how interesting so I started
writing about that and probably spent a
lot of a lot of the past decade writing
about similar topics from you know
Equatorial Guinea in Kazakhstan and
Angola lied in to Cambodia and all over
the world looking at this topic so like
a lot of journalism stories you know you
you get on to a
you start writing about it people start
bringing you tips and you keep writing
on it what is you know there's a lot of
talk and development economics but the
resource curse and we saw that verse and
with the Obiang family and with other
countries that have discovered oil or
natural gas or some other resource in
the last 10 20 years can you talk about
what what does it do to a country does
it actually make the people in the
country better off or does it make them
worse off because it frees their rulers
from the need to any sort of
accountability at all well it in general
it has made countries worse off but the
key thing is if you suddenly find oil in
the country where there is really no
form of democracy and no history of
democracy like Equatorial Guinea where
you know gains independence from Spain
it was a colony of Spain until the 60s
1968 they gained independence and this
literally a Idi Amin type character a
complete lunatic takes power terrorizes
the country and then 11 years later his
nephew execute him overthrows him and
then executes him and has held power
ever since there's no tradition of
democracy so you you you know in that
environment when a government gets its
hands on that sort of oil wealth it's
almost inevitable that it leads to
corruption and very very little
improvement for people of the country so
in Nigeria for example Nigeria if you
know oil firms have been pumping oil
there for I think nearly half a century
now and the country is certainly worse
off not better off I remember talking to
former CIA official who had traveled to
Nigeria
he wasn't stationed there but he was
worked for the office it was then called
and so maybe called the office of
transnational threats and he went to
Nigeria and he said he concluded on the
basis of conversations with people that
the country would have been better off
if they never discovered oil so if you
know in a lot of places a lot and as I
note in the book a former Vice President
Cheney once noted God didn't see fit to
put oil only in democratic countries
finally to the United States and when
the oil is found in Kazakhstan or
Azerbaijan or Equatorial Guinea or chat
or Cameroon the odds are it's not going
to do the people a lot of good you know
there are some countries Norway
which has a long history of democracy
and citizen lovely Norway's done pretty
well on oil but so it's not you know
it's not automatic it really depends on
that context in the environment the
United States well I guess the United
States is a mixed bag in in some ways
you know certainly and again when you
you know refer to a conversation that he
had as part of the book with a former
Chevron executive Edie Chow who is now
at a he's at the Center for Strategic
Strategic and International Studies and
he talked about the difference between
development of oil resources in he was
talking I think specifically about
Central Asia Kazakhstan and Azerbaijan
where he Chevron has enormous
concessions there and they obtained them
when he was at Chevron and he said look
the difference between Kazakhstan in the
United States for a Central Asia in the
United States is you know in in in the
u.s. the oil resources are not owned by
this this state you know the individual
landowner in Texas or Louisiana gets
royalties you you know the companies
pump the oil the landowner gets the
money sometimes there's not a huge
environmental footprint you know the
companies are making money they create
jobs and they create some wealth now
certainly you can look at Texas and
Louisiana which is a state I look at
very closely in the book and you can see
in Louisiana there are certain elements
of the traditional third world resource
curse where you know the country has a
lot of oil wealth but it hasn't been
shared very well and the you know in
terms of social indicators Louisiana
ranks pretty low on just about
everything in terms of health and
education and and per capita income but
this is generally been a problem with
Louisiana government right
that it just broadly there's a lot of
corruption it's it's very different from
the rest of I mean I don't want to say
there's no corruption anywhere else but
it the political culture in Louisiana it
does seem to be very different basically
any other state in the u.s. so I mean is
it broadly when you look at taxes when
you look at those places do you see the
same level of problems or is it no
definitely and that's where getting at
is that it's the political context it's
true Louisiana has been notorious for
corruption for a long time so and the
United States is not a we have all sorts
of political problems but we're not
Kazakhstan just yet and so yeah the
wealth generated by oil has been better
for people in the United States
certainly than it's been for you know
residents of West Africa oil-rich West
African countries so that political
context is is very important which is
not to say oil has not created problems
as well as everyone knows I mean you
know from environmental problems I guess
would be the main one that people think
about and also you know other I guess
that would be the main one in the United
States that people worry about the most
you don't talk so much about fracking
which surprised to me a little bit I
mean Wyatt why did you just because I
suppose because that's the big you know
political issue in the u.s. right now
did you think about doing more on it or
did you decide that really the focus was
on conventional oil well the focus of
the book really is looking at the
middleman the the book is called the
secret world of oil because I'm trying
and hopefully succeeded to some extent
in shining a light on a part of the oil
industry the internet really the natural
resource industry that that doesn't
receive a lot of attention which is the
role of traitors and intermediaries
middlemen fixers whatever you want to
call them these are people who through
you know there's a stratum between the
companies and the government's in in
some of these more corrupt countries
where you know you don't if you want to
oil concession in Kazakhstan or
Azerbaijan you know it's not like you
submit a bid and there's a you know the
government meets in a closed door and
says let's see what's going to be the
best deal you have to grease the wheels
and there's
other way of putting it you don't get an
oil deal in Kazakhstan without making
government officials wealthy you know
you the old model was well we'll just
transfer some money into your Swiss bank
account and now it's a lot more
complicated and the companies definitely
I'm not saying that every oil deal is
legally corrupt in spirit they're
probably all corrupt but you you know
you you cannot do business in many
places in the world and you know
especially oil is such a sensitive
commodity I mean it's it's you know you
oil and weapons are the two most
important commodities to any government
you know you can't run your economy
without oil and you can't defend your
borders without weapons and partly
because of that you know there's a very
centralized decision-making you know
only a few people are in on that and
especially and again these countries
that I keep referring to you know in
Central Asia and West Africa you know
where you have either dictatorships or
authoritarian governments however you
want to put it you have very few people
making decisions and so the key to
getting a deal in these places is often
having the right fixer having the right
middleman you can't do business and in
some countries without a door opener and
the door opener is typically a person
who has over the years built up trust
and confidence and access to senior
government officials or the president
often and can get you in the door and as
I said the old model was you know you
just okay well what's your Swiss bank
account well you know we used to wire
the money and now it may be for example
in Equatorial Guinea Exxon and and
Chevron and Amerada Hess and various
other oil companies got deals over there
and they were investigated by the US
government never charged for reasons
that that I find surprising because they
they enriched the government they didn't
reap enriched the president now they
didn't as far as I know simply you know
wire cache but they for example bought
land from the president you know he oh
we we want to we want to build our
compound oh really you own the land is
that right so we'll just buy it from you
or they hired a security firm in
Equatorial Guinea several other
companies hired a security for to guard
their their compounds in their their
installations and the security firm was
owned by the brother of the president
who was identified in State Department
reports as a torturer you know there
several of the companies made president
Obiang a partner on business deals where
he mysteriously didn't even have to put
any money down they just said we'll just
give you a cut you know like I think
Exxon gave him a 20 percent cut of an
oil distribution business that was it
wasn't that there it wasn't you know it
wasn't the oil concession itself but it
was a oil distribution company and I
think they gave him 20 percent for
nothing down well we'll just take it out
of your royalty cheques and then after
we you pay you you get you pay for your
share out of out of profits then it all
just goes to you I wanna ask you about
this because you know these deals are
being structured that way precisely
because of the Foreign Corrupt Practices
Act and some people would say look look
this is the this is the price that we
are gonna pay that kind of
definitionally oil is being discovered
and more developing countries precisely
because it was it was exploited a
hundred years ago in the u.s. although
another place i saw there now with
fracking you know it's less true but
that because of that you've got
countries whose borders were drawn by
colonial powers no institutional history
before the European powers pulled out
weak local you know often with
cross-cultural borders that bisect
ethnic groups and so forth that in these
weak institutional States you have
corruption you're going to get
corruption and that the price of getting
the oil is being willing to pay why
should we hold us companies accountable
to a higher standard and let the French
companies go in and bribe anyone they
want and get all the oil concessions I
mean what would you say to that okay
well first I do want it because I
realize also didn't
just quickly I didn't answer your
previous question about why I didn't
write much about fracking and the reason
is because fracking is now developing
and it's a it's a newer form of
development and there is now you know
it's an international business as well
but I was looking at fixers who arranged
deals between yeah the old established
happens but that have never really been
written yet or developed its own
barnacle like in crustaceans exactly and
they're also you know in most I mean the
fracking industry now is expanding but
you know it's it's a lot of the business
is domestic you don't have middlemen
here or at least not in the same way in
terms of the other question you asked
though about why you know why shouldn't
we you know okay we just have to
tolerate corruption because it's it's
part of the environment and and to
certain extent there's true I mean that
that's true there's no way unless you're
going to say we just won't get oil
anymore we'll survive without it which
isn't going to happen you know we can't
you know you can't you have to be
practical and realistic to a certain
extent I mean I'm not saying and I don't
think anyone serious can argue that you
know let's just not do business anymore
with Saudi Arabia because even if we
didn't right that's the French would buy
the oil then we'd buy the oil from the
exactly right you wouldn't accomplish
much anyway but I do think that you you
know it's not just that we're getting
the oil and that's it there it's not
just a passive relationship we go in and
you know develop the fields and and take
the oil it's much much more complicated
and and entrenched than that so you have
I mean I I do think it's wrong when
American oil companies again to cite
Equatorial Guinea where you go into a
country like this which is dirt poor and
where you you know you can say well
there's you know you can't do business
over there without somehow making the
government officials happy well they
made him very very happy I mean Obiang
is one of the richest men in the world
one of the richest rulers in the world
at this point and his son who has had a
30 million dollar home in Malibu seized
or it's his there's an asset forfeiture
complaint by the US government and he
commissioned at one point a 315 million
dollar yacht he's like a 45 year old
do-nothing kid who his father installed
to head the you know Department of the I
think it's the Department of Environment
which people jokingly referred to as the
Department of chopping down trees so
he's making money on the timber trade
and then just clearly appropriating
money from the oil wealth right so you
know you can say well we tell what we
have to tolerate a little bit of
corruption but they're not just
tolerating there they're facilitating
mass corruption and beyond that they
then in order to secure their hold there
they're possessed a their their
interests their they then lobby for
these government so you have the
American oil companies who are actively
promoting Obiang as oh he's a reformer
which is just preposterous I mean
they're they're trying to develop an in
trench a relationship with the US
government on the basis of a fraud you
know this guy has been you know he's
held power since 1979
he's been reelected in quotes three
times the last time I believed if 99
percent of the vote you know so you have
your why the 1% right why all the way
incredible so but you know they so you
you build a relationship and you become
a partner it's so it's not a passive
relationship so that's part of it and I
also think you you see repeatedly time
and time again you know I don't reduce
American foreign policy to oil I think
that's too simplistic at the same time
anyone who looks at American foreign
policy and ignores oil I mean that's
equally preposterous and you look at US
history and you look at the
relationships that we've developed you
know they haven't it's not like there
hasn't been blowback in some of these
cases I mean you know we have a deep and
long relationship with the Saudis that
is pretty controversial and hasn't been
in you know cost some pain
you know it's not just an ethical issue
it's a practical issue as well I mean
post 9/11 in fact one of the reasons you
know there was an argument oh we've got
to move away from Middle East oil you
know just look at all the trouble it's
caused us oh ok so we'll move into West
Africa and Central Asia that'll solve it
because those are stable good
governments so it's it's it's I knew
think there's an ethical argument but
honestly you know there's no way one can
can simply say oh we have to have a
perfectly ethical energy policy because
yeah I mean other governments don't
don't play that way but there are also
practical considerations and it's
definitely been costly in many ways to
to the United States and and the public
to maintain these relationships with
some of these countries so talk about
some of those costs about how it has
cost the American public to keep in with
the corrupt dictators well I mean if you
look at look at the Middle East I mean
what is our base what is the basis of
our relationship with with these various
Middle Eastern countries it's pretty
much oil I mean I again I don't want to
reduce it's it's strictly to that but
you know I mean there's a former it's
real also a big that's true that's true
absolutely there definitely but part of
the relationship with Israel in fact is
because it is our closest ally in a
region that is oil-rich so there's a
strategic and there's an energy related
issue there too but yes no it's not
strictly oil definitely not however it's
important it's very very significant I
mean you have former he was a Deputy
Assistant Secretary of Defense under
Reagan Lawrence Korb who's now Senate I
think he's at Center for American
Progress
he once said you know if the Saudis
exported artichokes we wouldn't have a
close relationship with them and you
know look at the war in Iraq once again
yes it's not purely about oil but is
there any way that the architects of the
war in Iraq were sitting around the room
thinking about whether to invade or not
not thinking about well that it is a
major they do have huge oil reserves
to be on the table if it wasn't then
really these people are completely I
mean it would have to be almost because
of course the original invasion of
Kuwait was about arguments over that
reserve straddles the you know who was
draining too much from the reserve break
it straddles the Kuwaiti in Iraq Porter
so it always said I agree it always does
come down to I'll and much of the Middle
East which what should we be doing
differently well certainly you know my
book is really it's there's not a grand
theoretical argument I mean I have
worked as an investigative reporter and
I am NOT you know I I have no I don't
want to promote myself as a you know a
huge just pull up the rock and see
what's under yeah yeah that's what I
like to do I mean that's and so I you
know there's there's not a grand theory
I just try to write about things that I
think are interesting and hope other
people do too but in terms of what we
should be doing differently you know
obviously I don't think anyone would say
even the oil companies wouldn't say we
should I'm not sure whether they you
know through we are dedicated to the
idea but you know to the extent that we
are reducing our dependence on fossil
fuels it's better I mean you have all
sorts of reasons you know for
environmental global warming there are
all sorts of negativities from our
dependence on oil everyone talks about
it I mean every time there's a
presidential election both presidents
are both candidates talk about how we
have to reduce our dependence on foreign
oil and even in general there's are now
consensus that we probably should be
using less fossil fuels so you know that
is that a cure-all of course not
you know but I do think as I write about
in the book oil is certainly by almost
any measure the most corrupt industry in
the world I would say the energy
industry and you know there are a
variety of reasons for that one of it
one of them is as as
you pointed out you know there's a lot
of oil is is is in corrupt countries so
that's just the way things happened or
right you know or if you believe that
God planned it I don't know but that's
where a lot of the oil has traditionally
been town but also because oil is you
know the when you when you're looking if
you're an oil company American Chinese
French whatever and you're looking at a
deal in Kazakhstan if you're trying to
obtain a concession in Kazakhstan I mean
it's going to matter to your corporate
bottom line for a long time and in a
significant way whether you get that
deal or not it's not like oh we sell
socks and we lost this deal you know to
provide ten thousand pair of socks you
know an oil concession you're talking
about tens hundreds of billions of
dollars and so they're the incentive to
get the deal is huge and the incentive
to maybe cut corners a little bit
is also huge and so you see if you look
at number four in corruptive act
practices Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
cases prosecutions by any measure the
two industries that come up most often
are weapons and oil and partly it's
because the deals are so huge and partly
it's because as I referred to earlier
you typically have very very few
decision-makers you know if you you
don't need to gain wide public support
you need to get the attention of the
president of a country or the oil
minister and the way to do that
typically well it's so fun joyful and so
easy to steal which was God's I mean I
was fascinated by I did a lot of work on
the economy of Iraq after the invasion
and the ways in which like the pipelines
were carrying we're running at half of
normal capacity because people had just
drilled holes and pipelines and we're
stealing it the oil was just it would
disappear and it would get tranship
somewhere else and of course it's
theoretically possible to trace chemical
signature as an oil to figure out where
it came from but in practice once you've
moved it out of the country and gotten
it into the market it's a valuable
commodity that's that's pretty much
so you're always going to have quite a
lot of incentive I would think to bribe
I'll ask one more question and then we
have to go to our break but you know
what was the most surprising thing that
you are the most outrageous thing or the
most interesting thing that you came
across when you're researching this book
well I guess the most surprising thing
in some ways was when in talking to oil
company officials or the middlemen who
are focus of the book the you know
wouldn't talking to industry insiders
and a lot of them would only talk off
the record but not all I mean there are
a number of people in the book who did
agree to talk on the record the the sort
of casual acceptance of corruption was
sort of surprising to me because I did I
guess I didn't expect people to be so
forthright about it because publicly of
course nobody ever says what they say in
private you know and in this case you
know in private the companies would
never say yeah of course you know we
can't work in Equatorial Guinea without
paying off senior government officials I
mean give me a break
but in private that was the attitude was
you know I had a Swiss oil trader who
said and he did speak off the record but
he said something along the lines of hey
you can call it corruption but it's part
of the system and said there was just a
you know an openness about it that in
some ways was surprising and and and
people talked about I was intrigued and
interested to hear about the new forms
of corruption where you're you know
where people said yeah we can't just you
know pass a bag of cash under the table
anymore or or wire the money and so now
it's it's got to be much more
sophisticated so you'll have the oil
Minister's nephew open a company in the
British Virgin Islands which can't be
traced to them normally anyway and and
that company is hired to do some
consulting service which of course
they're not doing anything they're just
a recipient of money that somehow will
find its way to the ministers
I can't say it was shocked but I was
surprised in some ways with the openness
and and an intrigued and interesting
well there is actually a defense that
you hear and a lot of the developing
world of corruption on the grounds I
mean there was that that joke that went
around about Hillary Clinton talking to
some foreign minister of somewhere who
said you know you call it corruption we
call it Family Values but that in fact
in clan based societies that this sort
of thing is actually you would be
shirking your moral obligations and also
that you know in in some ways if you
don't have the ability to raise taxes
what you end up with is corruption to
pay people off that's how police worked
in New York in the nineteenth century I
mean is that at all fair that these are
states that don't have taxing power and
corruption is what they have instead I
think it's a bit self-serving and and
and and an apology for behavior that
really isn't most people wouldn't find
acceptable it's not I mean I wouldn't
say that it's entirely false I mean I
certainly heard another oil trader I
talked to in Switzerland said he made
this argument he said look you know in
the United States you know you pay you
you make country yeah Goldman Sachs
makes political contributions and in the
third world we you know you just based
on money same thing I I don't think one
can dismiss that argument I mean we have
a different way of doing things but
there is it's legalized corruption in a
sense but the argument that it's
clan-based and you know it just doesn't
really hold up if you travel to these
countries I mean I been to Equatorial
Guinea I intend goal I've been to a
number of countries in in western Africa
and yes it's true you know the the money
is distributed by the head of the tribe
or the clan but in in these places you
can just see with your own eyes and you
you know Angola the president of the
country is living in this mansion
overlooking this sprawling slum the
wealth just isn't going far well with
that I have to stop who's we're gonna
take a short break and we will be back
in a few minutes
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
you know we've been talking about the
the countries on the corruption there
now I want to move on to the the people
in the middle because you have some very
theatrical characters you are
facilitating all of these contracts can
you tell me you talk about the traders
and the fixers and the gatekeepers
what is the difference when a fixer and
a gatekeeper there's not a huge
difference actually I mean they do
similar things basically you have the
fixers are - it's traditionally been a
relatively small group of people you
know maybe a dozen or a few dozen people
who have you know in various parts of
the world have sufficient access to the
President or the top government
officials that you pretty much have to
do business through them and so if you
want to get a deal in Nigeria for
example for a long time there were a few
people you could go to one of them was a
guy named joe biacchi Gori who is a
longtime friend of Bill Clinton a major
major donor to the Clinton Foundation
and had pretty close ties to the
Democratic Party
back during the Clinton years and he was
a guy who you know nobody knows exactly
quite how he did it but he had access to
the senior senior government officials
in Nigeria and so you you know it wasn't
just oil because he had all sorts of
relationships there he would broker a
lot of deals there but you know you you
go to shag or E and you you know you you
hire him as a consultant and you
miraculously end up with big contracts
over there or there's another guy this
is an interesting story uh Jim Giffen an
American who was very very
well-connected in the former Soviet
Union from the from the very beginning
from the very earliest post communist
period and so
he was actually indicted by the US
Justice Department and charged with I
don't know if the word bribes work this
was this was back in it was about ten
years ago when when Giffen was was
charged and he had this move money he'd
been hired by US oil companies as a
consultant in Kazakhstan and he was
charged with funneling I think eighty
million dollars into this was the old
model into accounts controlled by the
prime minister and president of
Kazakhstan and you know he was a guy who
had a very close personal relationship
with the president he you know he had a
house in in the fanciest neighborhood of
the capital in Kazakhstan when when the
President Nazarbayev came to Washington
given would show him around
take him to to meet with Washington
officials you really couldn't hope to do
business over there without hiring him
on as a consultant so he was indicted
and and charged and the case dragged on
for years and years and years and he is
he basically used a gray male defense I
I don't want to say that he he
acknowledged that he had made payments
to the president although it's clear he
did he bought the president and his wife
a matching snowmobiles and he jewelry
for the wife and believe he paid the
tuition of a daughter who attended
college here in the Washington area but
in the end he basically said well
everybody knew what I was doing I mean
this was not a mystery you know I was
talking to you know the State Department
and I think he said the CIA and
everybody knew what I was doing
everybody knew what what my relationship
was and so you know why are you
bothering me and in the end he he he
basically got off and the judge in the
in the case said you know you've been
persecuted you were really
I think he even used the term American
hero and said you were trying you were
helping us oil companies get concessions
that were important to the United States
and so the whole it would became known
as every you know it was known here as
Kazakh Gate because of course we
attached gate to every scandal but he
ended you know he was he was never
charged and so it was one of the he's
one of the interesting characters I
think in the book though well it's
interesting it's not clear exactly how
one becomes a fixer sir is there an
application process you know swimsuit
competition
what's it how did these guys get the
connection I suppose that's the shadowy
process we don't really understand is
how these guys get the connections that
enable them to be trustworthy conduits
for these sorts of payments well
certainly it's sort of ironic because
you know it's an international oil
industry is generally pretty corrupt but
one way that people become fixers I
think is being trustworthy in the sense
that you know that they do have the
excess and you can't and you can arrange
you can arrange deals and that you're
good to your word so one of the people
who I write about he's the focus of
chapter one is a guy named le Khalil who
is he had a lot like Shakur he had a lot
of contacts and influence in Nigeria and
I talked to him extensively and as I
acknowledged in the book I came to like
him and become friends with him he's a
really fascinating character you know
very hard not to like one of the things
that you know there's no job application
but one of the things that I think is
part of the you know you you have to be
relatively charming and he's very very
charming hard not to like he he has so
he you know his his father was the
families of lebanese origin but grew up
in
in Nigeria and he told me that he had
initially how he got into the Milman
business he said was that his his family
was wealthy in Nigeria they had I it was
like a peanut business or something and
he said at some point someone from who
was a friend of who or maybe related to
his sister from a middle-eastern
airline said you know we're looking for
business and Nigerian we need an
introduction and he knew everybody he
was in you know because he went to
school with right he was in business
there I mean it wasn't he wasn't he was
a peanut processing business or
something but it was a significant
business still so he knew various
government officials and so he made the
necessary introductions and the deal was
struck and he said you know screw it why
am i dealing with peanuts when I can you
know be paid to use my contacts so it's
really you know it's it's hard to know
exactly or unless people are willing to
talk about it
how are the origins of the relationships
but you know when you do business in a
country like Equatorial Guinea or
Cameroon or even Nigeria which is the
larger larger you know you if you are a
prosperous businessman you you tend to
know government officials and you can
make use of that I was surprised by how
many of these people are not locals that
that you didn't have a lot of people who
are the fixers who are Cambodian or are
why is that is that because the oil
companies need someone international to
for some sort of communication or trust
or what do you have a sense of why so
many of these guys or America and a
French or what-have-you
well you know partly I think because you
are talking about middlemen who are you
know they're they're not they play this
role to to broker introductions between
the companies and the government's and
in part certainly American companies
because of Foreign Corrupt Practices Act
have have you know wanted to have a
certain distance you know like with you
know you want to be able to deny
plausible deniability about your
relationship with somebody so they hire
some you hire somebody also who is not
accountable to the Foreign Corrupt
Practices Act so you hire a European or
a middle Easterner who wouldn't
necessarily be I had no idea why this
land was so expensive but the guy told
me that this was the land I should the
best place to set our headquarters right
yeah that's what we bought right so but
there certainly are locals and and and
especially as industries have grown up
in Nigeria for example there are now a
lot of local middlemen who have gotten
very very wealthy brokering deals with
the government but initially in a lot of
these countries you know when you go
into a place where you're not familiar
you're you're looking for somebody who
can give you the lay of the land and who
you know I'm sure they they they have
their local context but often like in
Angola
BP at one point got into a bit of
trouble because they hired a to be
someone to be their spokesman it was
this okay it was either senior
government official or related to a
senior government official but often you
you know you you want somebody who's
probably a bit of an you know outsider
but who knows the country and can point
you to the right people so what about
the traitors we even talked about them
yet and that's a big part of this a big
chapter and a big part of the oil market
and you talk about Glencore it's huge
commodity operation what role do they
play in all of this
well Glencore is this enormous company
that a lot of Americans haven't heard of
they've heard of mark rich though the
founder that's right because mark rich
was famously pardoned he was charged
with trading with the enemy
Iran I believe was was the enemy that he
was trading with and he fled the United
States ahead of an indictment and then
on Clinton's last day in office he was
pardoned for reasons that have never
been fully explained that but that
alleged his ex-wife is very cozy with
the Clintons however they might have
something to do have something to do
with it and she made there were
extensive campaign contributions that
she made and certainly I think it would
be naive to think that that didn't have
something to do with with the pardon I
do hope to be writing another story
about that though and I think there are
other interesting reasons as well well I
can't wait to hear are you allowed to
dish on c-span or hold any time anyone
it's a really good story but I don't
want to I'll hopefully be telling it
sometime in the next few months it's
ironic because it's an old story but I
just learned it part of it that's very
very interesting and I will only say
that it involves favors that Marc Rich
did for the US government overseas you
are you're killing me it's a really good
story but I'll watch out for that first
like media so you know talking talking
you've got these big oil companies and
one of the things that you suggest
although is that they could be
manipulating oil prices is that you know
you have a passage actually where you
you say you know but for the past seven
years the price of oil had been swinging
wildly in the face of contradictory
supply and demand data after floating in
the 10 to $40 per barrel ranch for
almost 20 years it started to climb
sharply in 2005 when it crossed $70
after falling back a bit it spiked to
140 in the middle of 2008 but then the
price fell off a cliff done to
clinton-era price of $30 in just six
months within two years that are tripled
again do you think that that's the role
an OL economist might say that's sort of
the predictable response of getting to
the production frontier where we seem to
have you with fracking we're expanding
it a little bit but you know Chinese
demand seems to have collided with the
amount of oil that the world can
profitably produce
and that I mean do you how much a role
do you think that oil traders play in
that it's hard to measure and certainly
as with oils role in foreign policy you
know to say that it's purely a function
of manipulation of the market is is just
wrong there are all sorts of thing that
things that impact prices of oil I mean
you know a war in Iraq for example or
you know okay
right I mean there's all sorts of things
that are impacting the price of oil but
there have been periods where traders
certainly have have accelerated trends
either upward or downward I mean people
do make money on this business and you
know you're making money at the margin I
talked to you you know where I mean if
if the price per barrel changes by a
small amount the you know if you own
enough barrels are trading enough
barrels it's very profitable to be on
the right side of the of the curve
although also essentially unprofitable
to be on the wrong side of the curve and
sometimes they are although there was
someone who told me in the the in in in
talking about Glencore they said when
when Glencore is betting on the price of
oil to go up you don't want to be
betting on it to go down the goldman
sachs yes
so but but so I think there's a
contributing factor and and and there
have been times when traders have
certainly influenced prices I did talk
to a another Swiss trader who said look
you know when I started in this business
the paper trade versus the physical
trade meaning the r you know a real
barrel of oil versus just a you know if
the paper the the right survived right
the right to have a barrel of oil at
some point in the future he said at his
firm it was one too you know the ratio
was one to one and that currently it's
more like 40 or 50 to one he said come
on you know there it's there's there's a
huge huge paper trade and there you know
it is subject trader
Glencore I'm not want to be clear here
I'm not accusing Glencore specifically
of manipulating markets but Glencore
trades 3% uh
that yet moves 3% of the daily oil daily
oil trade nothing and it's not even the
biggest oil trader there are other firms
that are that are bigger so you know
there's an ability to manipulate markets
which i think has happened at times and
you know what how do you see that what
does it show up does it show up in Swift
movements of daily presses or does it
show up in a movement in one direction
or the other I think it as I said
believe it it it is not ever going to be
the the one factor that you know so
you're not going to see you know that
because of manipulation of the markets
but if you see the market going like
this naturally you might see it going a
little bit sharper because because of
the manipulation of oil prices so it
basically accelerates whichever way the
markets already going yeah and I
wouldn't say it accelerates it all the
time but there have been times clearly
where traders have I where it appears
that traders have certainly contributed
to downward and upward movements did you
get to see I mean you know go inside
these operations and see how they look
you know talk about what happens what
isn't real trader do all that well it's
not that I mean you know the actual oil
trader is like going to a Wall Street
firm I mean it's not that exciting and
it look I went to a couple of these
firms they're you know hyper corporate
you know very very fancy and what one of
the firm's I went to in in Geneva was I
guess you know a little bit more
polished here than our c-span studio
here you know what you're saying they
had you know the furniture was was
polished to a sheen let's say and you
know I believe when we opened the
conference door it was an electronic
door but you know you're you're you're
looking at a computer screen and you're
you're looking at the price of oil so
that you know the daily I think it's
probably a lot like being a Wall Street
trader yes women have been I actually
used to work on trading floors before I
became a journalist as a tech not not
trading anything
and they're now so quiet they weren't
what I worked there in the 90s but now I
wanted to build grosses at PIMCO's
world's largest bond fund it's like a
library it's totally quiet it was that
pretty much what I saw if the firm's I
was at it wasn't hugely exciting but
they did it was interesting because I
did talk to traders about what they did
at night which tends to be more
interesting which when they were wining
and dining you know I mean I talked to
one one trader who said that you know he
and he was working on the upstream side
so he was selling refined products to
you know like to buyers in in Asia you
know needed large quantities a lot of
karaoke exactly exactly so they did a
lot of entertaining in the evening and
he said you know that's again that's you
know part of the way the business is
done you know we take these guys out
it's more than just karaoke frequently
and they gain access to information yes
and discover what you know that's how
they got a lot of their contracts right
you read the history of sales in the
1960s in the United States it sounds
very similar probably not entire up some
girls and get some drinks right yeah
that's the central part of the business
I think and and why why is the paper
trade increased so out of whack to the
you know why is that why is everything
happening on paper instead of a real
barrels well I confess I really can't
give you a detailed answer to that I
wrote a little bit about speculation in
the book it wasn't a central part of the
book maybe it should have been because
it is a topic that's sort of interesting
but I think it's it's in the same way
that you know Wall Street trading hey
you know so much of the the trade now is
you know these highly sophisticated
products that nobody really understands
and I think it's it's probably just
followed you know it's it's a similar
trend but I really I I can't give you a
good answer
lobbying so we're now tracing through
the rest of the but a lot in here so
we're you know how
it is how different is this from other
kinds of lobbying does it is it special
or is it basically the same old dance
that is done in every state Capitol and
in every country in the world well I
wrote in the book about a little bit
about federal lobbying and then I wrote
extensively about Louisiana and the
situation there and you know to certain
extent yeah it's the same old deal I
mean you know you've got in you know the
oil industry is very powerful and
influential it you know it's not a
standalone industry in that regard
obviously I mean there it's one of um
you know I would say it's one of the
more powerful in lobbying forces because
it's a huge industry and so they do what
other industries do they just do more of
it
you know they hire more lobbyists they
you know they pay more money they get
more meetings and they do have an
advantage in that because oil and gas
are central to you know running the
economy and to you know frequently plays
a role in foreign policy you people are
in government are very open to arguments
about the need to you know help out the
the industry so over the years the
industry has has done quite well in
Washington in Louisiana you know I think
because Louisiana the the industry has
always been so influential there at the
state level and because it's the large
if you include the offshore then
Louisiana's offshore component of the
you know the federal offshore holdings
it's a big I I think it's still the
biggest offshore per-capita producer and
as we discussed earlier Louisiana really
does have a particular culture and it's
it's an interesting place and a fun
place to report from you really can't go
wrong reporting for us Louisiana you
always meet interesting people and and
eat great food as well for the most part
I could spend my time in a fair amount
of time in strip halls as well
Claire but you know the situation in
Louisiana is I think it's clearly one of
the states where the industry has the
most influence and when they want
something they tend to get it and I was
you know I tell the story in in the book
about getting a couple of very lucky
breaks in Louisiana one of them was that
I went to interview a lobbyist one of
the most powerful lobbyists in the state
certainly ginger Sawyer and we had a
long conversation during which she was
extraordinarily forthright about the
influence of the industry and how they
were able to gain support of lawmakers
and sort of laid out to me the details
of how they had you know pushed a bill
through the legislature in the previous
session and I kept thinking what why are
you being so so forthright with me it
was like I told you I was a reporter and
then I was gonna write this down exactly
that's I kept that's what I kept
thinking and I was you know taking notes
it's not like I was you know making but
it turned out at the end of our
interview we talked for several hours
and when I got the bill and was had
given my credit card to pick up the tab
she said you really don't look anything
like like I expected I thought you were
appalled and I immediately knew what had
happened there's another ken Silverstein
who he actually is based in West
Virginia but he writes a lot about the
oil industry but he writes for trade
industry publications and he's very very
I would say much more sympathetic to the
industry and circumspect than I am and
so I was like I felt obliged to say I
think there's been a misunderstanding
and but I did I because of that
misunderstanding I did hear a lot of
very very interesting stories and to her
great credit even afterward and she
clearly was surprised when I said I'm
not that ken Silverstein but she talked
continued to talk to me all along
although after
it was originally as the chapters based
on a piece for Harper's Magazine
I haven't spoken with her much since
then so Neil Bush you close with him why
well really truly because it's an
interesting and funny story I think I
mean Neil Bush is the brother of George
W Bush and the son of George Bush Senior
of course and he's just had an curious
and really astonishing career in the oil
industry which doesn't appear to be it
certainly hasn't been based on his
success because he's failed repeatedly
time and time again I mean he has a you
know you would say a track record
unblemished by success and yet people
have over the years continuously
partnered with him and it's really hard
to understand why unless it's because of
his family name certainly he hasn't done
as well in the Obama years but if Jeb
Bush were to become president again I
would think that his star would rise so
I I you know truly it was because I
thought it was a funny story and an
interesting story and a reflection in
some ways of the way not just the oil
business works it's really the you know
it's the way the world works it's the
way the business world works
Chelsea Clinton seems to had a number of
astonishing yes and getting paid an
astonishing amount of money so but I
thought it was a funny story and the
truth is that my editor I discussed it
and it didn't really fit anywhere else
and we didn't want to lose it so that's
the truth is that's how it ended up
being the last chapter how did you get I
mean I was gonna ask this and then you
you provided one story but you got a lot
of people to talk to you on the record
and how do you how do you make that
approach I I don't know I don't I don't
know why I'm always surprised at why
people in some ways why people talk to
journalists although I often think it's
a smart thing to do I mean because you
know well even you know I think even
though I'm critical of the industry I
generally was good
my word with people I mean I I told them
if they ask I'm pretty critical of the
industry I also think I spoke to a lot
of people are who are confident and
powerful and don't have in some ways a
lot of doubts but it will also feel like
you know they've done a lot of
interesting and important things and
they're not embarrassed by what they've
done and they feel like they have a good
story to tell but frequently as a
journalist you know you're you may be
writing a story and you think why even
bother you know it's obviously I'll
never get the call returned or they'll
be angry or it'll be in no comment so
why bother but people talk to you for a
lot of different reasons sometimes it's
vanity sometimes it's pride sometimes
it's just because they're open-minded
sometimes it's because they're confident
and usually it's some combination of
these things so what you don't see of
course in the book is the number of
people who didn't talk to me and that
would they far outnumbered
the ones that did talk to me did you
give any I've always loved the excuses
that people come sometimes people are
just upfront but sometimes I once had a
company tell me that every single person
who worked for the company would be
traveling for the next month and a half
until my deadline it's like I will talk
to them and they said no no everyone's
traveling it's very busy schedule what
was the best turndown you got for an
interview well the best turndown I got
mostly I just you know I've never heard
I just never heard
Glencore never I requested interviews
with Glencore and they were very busy I
so it wasn't quite as Extreme as in your
case but it did seem like for a very
very long time no one was available no
matter where I was going to be or was
willing to go so well I think we're out
of time but thank you for spending an
hour talking to me and thanks to the
viewers for spending an hour listening
thank you